Of the
entire White House,
Donald Trump's former
White House press secretary.
The violence
we saw yesterday at our nation's
capital was appalling.
Didn't realize the full extent
of the violence at the Capitol
until she settled in
to eat a turkey sandwich
for lunch on January six.
Kayleigh McEnany
telling the January six committee,
I initially went back to my office
to eat lunch
but I eventually turned up the volume
on Fox News.
McEnany
saying she was still piecing together
what was playing out at the Capitol,
not merely sitting by as the attack
unfolded.
I in no way, shape
or form would eat a turkey sandwich
if I thought the Capitol Hill
was being seized.
How White House
Officials Learned of rioters
storming the Capitol on January six
Just one of the details
emerging as the House Select
Committee releases
new batches of transcripts from roughly
a thousand witness interviews.
The Select Committee intends
to make public
the bulk of its non-sensitive records
before the end of the year.
A separate transcript revealing
how the White House crafted
a press release
in December 2020
calling for the firing of anyone
who accepted
the election
result hours
earlier than Attorney General Bill
Barr had told the Associated Press
there was no widespread voter fraud,
according to the draft press release.
Anybody that thinks there wasn't
massive fraud in 2020
election should be fired.
The press release was never sent,
and Barr resigned
from the White House later that month.
Since then, he hasn't
held back in criticizing Trump's
election lies.
I was
somewhat demoralized
because I thought, Boy,
if he really believes this stuff, he has,
you know, lost contact with with
he's become detached from reality.
And I went into this and would
you know, tell him how crazy
some of these allegations were?
There was never
there was never an indication of
interest
in what the actual facts were.
The trickle of transcript revelations
coming after the committee recommended
that the Justice Department
bring criminal charges
against former President Trump
there was a conspiracy
to defraud the United States
to exchange an honest
to goodness
presidential election
for a counterfeit election.
Trump's legal team
downplaying the committee's findings.
The report itself is not of much value.
It's written by politicians
for a political purpose
and dismissing its criminal referrals.
Even as Trump faces scrutiny,
from a DOJ special counsel
that is now investigating his attempts
to overturn the 2020 election.
I mean,
the referral itself
is pretty much worthless.
The Department of Justice
doesn't have to follow it.
Now, the committee has, of course,
released its final report,
but they have released
just a fraction
fill of the underlying evidence
they put out.
Fewer than 100 of their interview
transcripts so far.
They interviewed roughly
a thousand witnesses.
And we are expecting many,
many more transcripts,
many, many more tidbits
about how this all unfolded.
That's good,
because I don't feel
like you've been very busy
the last couple of months, years,
decades.
Sara Murray, great reporting, as always.
Thank you so much.
Let's discuss now
with former special assistant
to President George W Bush and USA Today
columnist Scott Jennings,
along with Democratic former
South Carolina state representative
Bakari Sellers. Guys, thanks so much.
Welcome to the show.
Scott,
the former
president railed
against the January six committee
after they referred him
to the Justice Department
for criminal prosecution.
One of his attorneys calls
the referrals worthless
and political noise.
I don't ask this question
from a legal basis politically.
Are they are they just noise
or are they worthless?
Or do they have something that
can actually resonate here?
Well, the lawyers say they're
worthless from a legal perspective
because the DOJ is going to do
whatever it's going to do outside of
what Congress says.
But as a political matter,
obviously, this entire process,
this entire unfolding of this
has taken a
toll on Donald Trump
along with other things.
But clearly, this is dragging him down.
I mean, look at the polling.
I mean, the nation has soured on Trump
even more than they already were.
The Republican Party is souring on Trump.
He's losing in head to head
matchups with Ron DeSantis.
When you match him
up against Joe Biden in a rematch
that nobody wants, he's losing badly.
So obviously this,
along with everything else
he's got going
on, has taken a real
toll on him politically,
even if the legal aspects of it
here are less than important.
Corey.
Do you feel like
my sense
was part of the rationale for doing this
was to put pressure
on the Justice Department?
Do you feel like the just department
needs to act
on these criminal referrals
for the select
committee investigation
to be seen as worthwhile in the
eyes of the American people?
Well, first of
all, I'm not
sure you can actually put pressure
on Merrick Garland
and the Department of Justice.
I think
this Department of Justice,
compared to the one
that we've seen with Jeff Sessions
and Bill Barr,
and I can't remember
the guy who was there for
like a blink of an eye.
He was there for like once a year.
He met Whitaker
maybe I think it's his name.
That was a more political Department
of Justice,
whereas this is a Department of Justice
that can't really be pressured.
But what I can say
is that the information
this garner from the January six
committee does provide a roadmap
for the special prosecutor
to maybe, just maybe come with charges
from January 6th.
I don't think Donald Trump
has that much legal jeopardy
from January 6th.
I do think that individuals around him
who obstructed justice
usually it's not the crime,
it's the cover up
have a great deal of exposure
from January six.
I think that Donald Trump
has the most exposure field
from actually
taking a classified documents
down to Mar a Lago.
I think that
when you see his handling
of those classified documents, that and
what's going on with Bennie Willis
and the Cat County, Georgia,
Fulton County, Georgia,
those are the cases that
that probably give him more exposure
than January six.
Impressive recall of Matt Whitaker's
distinguished tenure
at the Justice Department.
Scott,
there's a New York magazine cover story
which writes
about Donald Trump's 2024
campaign in an article provocatively
titled Trump
Sad, Lonely, Thirsty,
Broken Basically
Pretend Run for reelection.
Trump adviser tells Olivia
that this campaign, quote, It's
not there in this business.
You can have it.
And have it's so hot
and it can go overnight
and it's gone and you can't get it back.
I think we're just seeing it's gone.
The magic is gone.
Is the magic gone
for the former president at this point?
Well, he's certainly losing altitude.
I mean, look,
he's he's
not without
things to build a campaign out of it.
He's got money.
He's got a cadre of advisers
who are fully dependent
upon him for their livelihoods.
He's got people who want Donald Trump.
I mean, there is a base of people
inside the party
that would rather have Trump
than than anybody else.
So that's not an insignificant thing
to start with.
But where he is lost
is that over the last
I mean, go back to 2016,
he backs into the presidency
and from that point forward,
losing in 2018,
losing in 20, 20, losing in 21, losing in
20 to all the legal stuff
that has come along.
Every Republican out
there is carrying his bags
and those bags are getting heavier
all the time.
So why do you want to call it
losing magic or whatever
It's just getting too,
too heavy to carry
Donald Trump's bags
because nobody wants to lose
to Joe Biden in 2024.
And that's what the
Republicans are coming
to terms with
and that's
why you see
people who look like winners
who feel like winners
like Ron DeSantis on the rise
and people
who've been losing
for a number of years
like Donald Trump thinking
you know Bakari the former president
is responding to the criticism on truth,
social writing.
We have almost two years to go.
The rallies will be bigger
and better than ever.
But it's a little bit
early, don't you think?
Is it too early to judge this campaign
or do you see real
vulnerabilities based on everything
that Scott just laid out in detail?
To some degree,
Well, the two points I like to make,
first is
I never counted Donald Trump
out of an election again in my life.
Like I firmly believe
we should be on the second term.
Of the Clinton presidency.
And so I was one of the many people
who was a prognosticator
and got paid good money to come up here.
And I was flat out wrong.
So I'm not going to count him out.
In fact,
his campaign was worse
then in 20, 15, 20, 16
than it is actually today.
There is a lot of stuff, like Scott
said, for him to build on
I wish Donald Trump,
if he was actually going to be
a good candidate, would simply say
Merry Christmas.
He would talk about
the joy of the New Year.
He would talk about the lessons learned
and maybe even tweet.
He has risen,
but he's not capable of doing that
and he hasn't changed.
And if you do not change,
if you do not learn,
if you do not have that,
if you do not mature in politics,
you'll get beat every day of the week.
And he hasn't been
able to do those things.